[Music]
it's sorry I had coffee in my mouth this
week we've got heavy party doughnut
robbery and cop standoff take it away
donut party take it away can we just
talk about that you make the tooth it
was heavy party and donut robbery donut
party I haven't had a donut in so long
[Music]
thank you fell a visit - no that's the
abyss of like his emptiness why is it
that Donuts taste the same wherever you
go
uh not Krispy Kreme donut self dad's I
guess that's the difference that's
that's one different place but then if
you go to any mom-and-pop donut shop
they're all different
I mean - all the same don't apart they
are all the same like if you go to
bakery like not a donut shop they're all
different like a mom-and-pop bakery yeah
I think you're talking about the
Cambodian donut shop yeah like special
donut shop friendly always pays they're
all different they're on a different we
thought about the Cambodian ones yeah
those are like boutique doughnuts yeah
they probably from the same place yeah
but what's crazy is that we don't care
we still give all of them are but I do
[ __ ] donut if you throw microwave
doughnuts like I like pizza is good you
know I mean like even if they suck
they're still not that very like
intimates I don't I don't like shitty
doughnuts I like doughnuts to eat it one
doughnut - the best I love all [ __ ]
dogs do we are we even supposed to be
talking about Donuts right now no those
for the next okay well let's continue
but for this first article here that we
have there was this apartment the
third-floor apartment that the floor
collapsed and all these people fell
through and they were at a party it fell
from the third floor to the first floor
second to the second oh I bet I was like
a sandwich like that
no third to second so this happened in
Texas and pass
10 Texas tenten tenten tenten did people
get smashed from the tower in the first
floor so luckily no one died but 6
people did get injured ok mister that
[ __ ] though if you're riding a rodeo all
day like if the floor breaks it should
be nothing right because that's how they
do in Texas yeah speaking of getting
injured I had a dream last night then I
got shot
besh it was crazy I had a [ __ ] dream
about you two days ago yeah I woke up on
my bed and it's crazy eyes dream he was
so sad he was sad Dave you told me I was
laughing you told me you're gonna commit
suicide
and I'm like Dave logic commit suicide
and then you know like you know what you
know I'm gonna do he's like you know how
YouTube still keeps making money right
I'm gonna assign all my adsense to
Daniel Mathews and I was like he needs
it Danny Kaye Dan oh yeah
probably are you guys even tight like
that and then I just walk by Oh what the
hell I'm kind of sad you would give your
money to David and on me yeah if you
were to give it to me out of it happy
that's a deep-ass dream dude yeah I'd
agree my just got shot did you feel the
actual bullet that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
paintball I was like oh my god the scene
do you like see yourself get shot or did
you like see yourself killed I was
inside a bar with everybody everybody
was there we're all chillin and then it
was like one of those like karaoke spots
and then some dude went up to the
[ __ ] thing but it said he had a gun
and he blasted me right my [ __ ] gut
and then he took off his mask and it was
me but it was a Mexican person so just
roll the [ __ ] Hospital and I think I
was having like a sleep apnea attack
because in the dream I like something
that was keeping my mouth open as [ __ ]
and then I started like choking it I was
like this is problem for my sleep apnea
and it just transferred into the dream I
couldn't breathe that's why I woke up
all that and then I started realize that
wait
get a shot that's when they wake up
versus like shot I got shot in the head
and I was laying then you've caught it
on your teeth and then I'm like and I
kept thinking like why am I not dying
but I could feel like the bullet would
anyway that's beside the point
we're talking about this apartment here
is that a Tiffany moment right I hate
this new brand name you guys gave me of
those what know if that's what you do
though but I think I like you know
light-hearted way that's what the boys
are so used to it remember when we were
kids
and we as a ball breakfast yeah was
breakfast like I don't know anyways back
to this apartment they were celebrating
the homecoming win for University of
North Texas UNT so this apartment
apartment complex is a jority of the
residents are students so they're saying
now after this happened some fat-ass
students mmm-hmm it was like around 2:00
a.m. on a Sunday morning and they were
just jumping like everyone just started
jumping on this and then this whole
thing ended up book that is scary
there's a bunch of football players I'm
now gonna like think twice when I jump
anywhere and like a bunch of us are
excited I've never seen you jump once in
my life when was the last time you
actually jump that's true I don't think
I've ever had to drop my whole life do
right now can I take tall people [ __ ]
like we don't John why you play Bobby
there we just read that's the last time
she jumped with volleyball yeah but I
mean the net six like barely sit no the
net is six so when I drop it's just like
I just needed like jump a little bit my
leg that's cuz you never played up five
six be an amazing I hope the [ __ ] get
his entire wins over the net I have yes
yes those are crazy here we go
[Music]
holy do they could sue right yeah oh my
god what the hell is that gas leak or
water you know what they might not be
able to sue because you know how like
every room they have maximum occupancy
if it's posted yeah yeah so if it's
posted somewhere like if that's an
apartment room maybe you're not supposed
to have like 80 people in there for sure
so they might not even be they might owe
them money
yeah oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] suck just
move very discretely wait was that a
school-sponsored dance or was it just
like after party everyone was like let's
hang out yeah that look like a house
party yeah so now about 50 people were
displaced following this and so the
manager displace meaning like bone
broken or like no meaning like like Oh
move move Oh nuts another general
manager of the complex totally resolute
Bay like that that a structure in
structural engineer will evaluate the
rest of the building that those are
affected by that they will be
compensated their lodging Expo that's
very nice oh [ __ ] what about the people
that got hurt well [ __ ] them nobody got
hurt at all he's juggling yeah probably
this [ __ ] slit six people that your
chance did that look like 30 20 buck
done thank God no one was on the second
floor yeah there was the people that
live downstairs
there's about five that there's about
five people that we get crushed no
they're saying luckily no one was in the
living room but all other stuff just got
destroyed
imagine you [ __ ] jacking off and
people fall through your ceiling but you
don't get hurt everybody like you're on
the couch jacking off and then the brush
they get up in your past like you're not
supposed to be here and you still not on
them you can't stop a nut right once it
starts going once it's gone there's no
point in so you're bout to climax right
and they're like give me your [ __ ]
money is it so like if it's you know the
face of the mmm no what is that there's
like that why'd she keep stroking me so
just there's a part of goes who feels
good but then once it gets to the what
to get to that face I just visualize him
being an entire dick we have a dog
barking Miyagi oh speaking of nuts sort
of next story here that they held up a
donut shop because of nuts donut I see
what you try to do there that's oh I
thought you better than [ __ ] whipped
out his dick and just robbed the place
we have almonds and cashews
yeah so these guys they're holding up a
donut shop and there was the yeah how
much money can you make a good donut
don't they know Cambodians on this
that's the worst move of your life they
will kill you might be a boutique one oh
no it looks like Cambodia what yeah so
there are these innocent people just
eating Donuts is there that's shop and
so these thieves they decided to go over
the counter grab some donuts and give
them to the innocent people I just so
happen to be there so I'm gonna show you
guys wait what you lost me really so
it's like a Robin Hood of don't know
they were also robbing money but it's
like while they were getting the money
they gave like their stress yeah we're
sorry to inconvenience you Dona hear
little bits compensate you with more
donut they're not gonna are they gonna
take the donut they might just be like
what the [ __ ] man yeah I'll show you
guys there's my minor maple bars can you
give me another one chocolate twist
security cameras caught this will
casually what interesting casual
suspects that grab doughnuts from behind
the counter popped over like you did a
million times
that [ __ ] as high as hell that's
super casual he's super high dude that's
not I love how you could tell what race
they are based off just the way he's
walking yep they were Asian if duffle
could have had a ski mask on trying to
cover his identity you are the black
hole guys they got [ __ ] swag the way
they can't even contain there's like
songs going off on the on his head he's
got a theme song
[Music]
with his name on the side because I
pretty sure if somebody came into the
store and they were always checking
their watch like this and they're just
the asian person now that [ __ ] was mad
swag if there's rhythm yeah black down
you when they rub somebody else [ __ ]
rhythm dude yeah
they'd make the worst secret agents like
mission impossible and once I call
trying to be discreet duffels the way
yeah yeah these guys got away so now the
cops are looking for them they look
super calm and collected like that's the
way to do a robbery if anything right I
might not even get mad if I was being
robbed by them like Dan'l super chill
and I feel like I was in danger how do
you don't you're still yawning like
that's like the most nurturing
compassionate robber because like he's
like yo I'm gonna have to inconvenience
you real quick so you don't call the
police but here's some doughnuts yeah
for your time even the way he took away
the phone yeah he's all nice don't trip
I'm gonna give it back yeah you know
what I want your phone at my parents
store you remember our training day yeah
where that fool had that shotgun under
his bed that I flipped the wrong oh yeah
you guys had that well I wanted to build
in a sawed-off shotgun in the front so
you could flip so you know like when
you're getting robbed [ __ ] you just cut
you could just blast them right through
the [ __ ] thing yeah yeah just blast
their guts open yeah I like all used to
it York's like you know what you're
getting robbed
oh [ __ ] happens bad but it's like oh
like that's like the best opportunity to
do it yeah you know so it's concealed
and you could just blast right through
the front cause it's like plywood
anyways but you don't do it like you
don't you don't do a swag the way Denzel
does it oh that's right cigarette he has
eyes all squinty oh yeah flicks the
cigarette and eat that hot space and
then he goes yeah yeah we're just black
no money no smoothness to it it's like
keep your money okay
Safety's on [ __ ] now hold on one second
[ __ ] give me two seconds alright
that's not a gun
I don't you Korean I don't get oh he
knows that he knows a different accents
Korean that sounds kind of racist you're
kind of racist bro for our last story
there were these undercover cops from
two separate precincts that were they
ended up being in a standoff with each
other this is oh my god it's sad but
awesome it's the department but on the
same team yeah [ __ ] crazy I always
thought about that like if I was an
undercover cop and then a cop came to my
house and we had it like a shootout why
do you think about that
you always think about them dad it was
the word always why are you thinking
about that I I mean I frequently thought
that this week was more but it is one of
those week we just changed always the
frequently sometimes think about this
this week this week always not my home
many times this week more than five
times that is frequent that's what is
that consider what is always free woman
is a good word well that frequently a
lot yeah yeah within a week span you
thought about it more than five times is
that always that is always for me okay
relative to the actual topic yeah not
like you're gonna go get mcdonalds right
each scenario was different it was in
different homes that I grew up in yeah
and I was like what am I gonna do like I
can't I don't want to blow the case like
I don't want like if I was working
undercover and I'm a part of this like
gang or whatever but then it's like you
know in the movies there's always like
the regular city cops that come and [ __ ]
up your investigation ways and I'm and
I'm like what the [ __ ] dude like this is
frequently this is not your jurisdiction
or like I'm an undercover and you're
gonna blow my case buddy but then we're
in a shootout I don't think you're
supposed to cuz remember that Oh anyway
were cool anyway yeah I know we're not
supposed to you gotta kill the cop I
know that's why I'm like oh I gotta
shoot back at them yeah you the guys are
gonna think I'm a cop yeah and I can't
do that because it's my investigation
isn't over or you got to be like a
Jackie Chan kind of thing where you like
beat the crap I don't want trouble and
you just kick like kick everybody job
well that's like every movie yeah that's
all one tribe oh that's how he wins the
fights because their guards are down you
always liked eyes or hands the other
with towels and like takes their guns
with this took place in Detroit and so
there were two undercover officers from
the department's 12th precinct and they
were conducting a push off operation
where they posed as drug dealers to try
to get would-be buyers to guys earlier
each other but they're both undercover
no no no these two first cops I
mentioned are the ones that are posing
as drug dealers
okay these other two undercover cops
they pulled you guys dollars from the 11
wires
thank you from the 11th precinct they
then approached them and then order them
and get down on the ground cuz they
didn't know that they were undercover
cops they started fighting each other
instead of navin actual drug suspects
that makes sense though yeah so that's
the thing here so it makes sense it's
just it's just a really funny question
because you would think someone up top
like the police chief who's kind of like
overseeing everything like hey 11th
precinct don't go to 12th precinct
they're doing a steamed over there so
you stay over you that's exactly what
people are saying like what the where's
the communication here like there should
have been communication ships 12th
precinct went into the 11th precinct
committee but that doesn't happen though
every time you watch a TV show or the
movies when it's like oh this is not
your Durst jurisdiction this is my
jurisdiction and they like battle it out
I'm just couldn't like scenes of a crime
organically developed in different
places right maybe they're like trailing
somebody and it's like oh [ __ ] dude
that's going into the 12th precinct zone
follow him still you know yeah I'm
undercover I I can't like just stop here
cuz not my jurisdiction I gotta know
seems like this 12th precinct though
they keep hooking up cuz with the 11th
precinct
previously officers from the 12th
precinct didn't properly notify 11
precinct during a prostitution sting and
then ended up being everybody started
[ __ ] each other
police say
under arrest I got you know I got you
all the prostitutes all the cider just
like yeah like hold on a second
communication is this prostitution or we
just [ __ ] yeah the pasta too is
undercover and the person who the [ __ ]
it was undercover to you they just got
the [ __ ] like a whole month straight
ya know communicate that sounds awesome
Johnson I'm going undercover
[Laughter]
[Music]